hey everyone welcome to LED live on this
episode we're going to talk about
depression
we've got Chad and Fadi a cruiser with
us from Anchor Point films if you've
ever been depressed what do you do find
out on this episode of LED live alright
welcome Chad and fatiah it's good to
have you here again and we've got
Michelle on the show with us this time
we're gonna talk about depression so
have either of you ever had depression
before I have yeah
it all starts for me it was it started
in actually I was in Iceland and while
in Iceland had stomach trouble actually
funny had stomach trouble another friend
work on this Nathaniel we all had
stomach trouble and for about two years
had stomach trouble and mine all stemmed
from partly you know the weather is
rough there but the other aspect was
this guy troubling now I didn't know
then and the gut-brain connection wasn't
wasn't as popular back then but study
after study has been coming out on the
effects of what's going on and the gut
and how it can affect the brain and
that's not a video on that right I do
yeah well so yes yeah we'll put the link
in the boat in below check that out we
have video from them about the gut brain
connection so if you want to learn more
about that we briefly touched on it in
the last program you can also get the
link to that as well but that we can
talk about another time or you can you
can check out the video so problem with
your guy yeah had a problem with my gut
and you know there it's it depression is
not only a gut issue it can be that can
be one that can be a major causative
factor but there's other various other
things that can cause depression
toxicity and various things but we're
gonna we're gonna get into some of those
in more detail things that people can
actually do to implement to reverse so I
had it for about 10 years off and on
even after coming back to the states my
stomach didn't fully heal after that and
then I would have seasonal depression
and after 10 years actually of this off
and on I was still traveling the world
still producing documentary film
still exercising and eating what most
people would consider a pretty good diet
but it wasn't working for me and then I
found something out and I'll share more
about that later on about that actually
ended up helping me so what about you
thought I should go through the same
thing I mean both I'm like I had I had
some issues there but not to the extent
that he did and mine or the years more
was situational I had an older brother
get killed and uh okay car accident and
he was killed by a drunk driver he was
killed by a drunk driver so it was just
very tragic and all that and you know
you go through these slumps and things
like that but in general not not to the
same degree that that he he was dealing
with yeah what about you Michelle you're
like always happy in the office always
smiling you ever had to deal with
depression you don't think so that's I
can notice no I don't you bro yeah
definitely you have I mean definitely
yeah as is probably as early as I can
remember it's been an up and down up and
down up and down so yeah I don't know if
there's anything necessarily cyclical
like time of year yeah but I definitely
have triggers now and there can be days
or it's it's hard to stay up and
positive and a lot of times you mm-hm
you know a lot of times you use things
or people even to to help cope with that
like my wife is very helpful it coping
you know there's its if we were to ever
both get sad at the same time it would
be very tough yeah yeah yeah in our
house but usually we can you know help
prop the other one up so that's good but
it can't be the only thing because
humanity can fail yeah you know other
things I don't know but what I find in
myself is typically you just don't ever
want to go to wherever those triggers
are ya know it's like you're it's like
masking the symptoms you know it's there
it's like lurking in the background but
you just kind of suppress it yeah and
keep it back so to that to date have
never been able to kick it you know
there
there are good days and bad days you
know I was thinking if you don't mind me
saying you would share that you have
some gut issues also and that can be
even though we don't associate it
because we think our depression is only
psychological we think it's just thought
processes and that and that is part of
it I'm not negating that fact but it's
amazing how many physiological things
can impact the brain so that it causes
thoughts and we think the thoughts or
what's causing the problem is sometimes
it's actually not the thoughts that
cause it Robert sometimes it's actually
the body is is causing a hormonal
release or some kind of physiological
process that makes us feel bad and when
you feel bad what do you have your bad
thoughts typically go along with it and
so we think the thoughts are the problem
and sometimes they are but sometimes
they're not so we're gonna talk about a
mixture of things as we as we go through
and one of the first things is one that
is probably not the primary thing but it
is something to think about is you can
potentially improve your mood with
negative ions now what what is that all
about negative eyes so we're gonna watch
a video clip my wife and I funny we
produce a documentary film series
actually we have one series but then
this particular individual documentary
is called ancient health it's like an
hour and a half documentary about the
longest-living people and the world
longest living cultures and we'll show a
video clip this is just a I don't know a
couple minute clip or something about
negative ions this is quite interesting
let's talk a little bit about air air
being one of the you know the acronym
and New START the a is for error and of
course we're speaking about good fresh
air what's surprising to many people in
the urban environments in which the
majority of the world's population lives
is that many of us are deprived of this
very important commodity there is
actually good air and better we know
that foul air in the cities will for
example double heart attack race which
is a big problem if you go into a
congested city environment you actually
don't you kind of feel a little down
your little gloomy the errors is just
not as fresh as compared to going along
a mountain stream with this this this
this river that's cascading down the
mountain
and the birds are singing the sense that
you have there and why is that in these
environments there are negatively
charged air ions we go out of the trails
and just breathe in just good air good
quality air the air around the
waterfalls lakes oceans pine trees cedar
trees mountains that negatively-charged
air is good for you it's actually
positive for you have you ever noticed
how good you feel after a thunderstorm
or after being by the ocean surf the
reason again is that these environments
create and have the highest
concentration of negative ions available
these negatively charged ions have a
mood elevating effect out there the
light rain when the rain comes to have
the negative ions go up all of that
fresh air anytime you can get out in the
fresh air you're gonna be better for
mentally and physically the brain needs
oxygen the nerve cells need oxygen to
function adequately and when you're not
sitting up straight and when you're not
breathing deeply then your tissues are
going to be lacking oxygen and you're
going to start feeling tired and
fatigued when we have this you know
oxygenation that's increased it really
does improve our mental ability and you
just feel much better I mean you feel
like my mind is clear and so it's very
important that we get that fresh air as
we want to improve our mental health and
our cognitive performance so getting
enough fresh air is actually valuable
and the quality of air is also very
important so my prescription for health
would include getting out into nature
get out after a thunderstorm and walk go
by the ocean surf go to an area that has
up in the mountains with lots of trees
get the best out of the time that you
exercise the thing is you can combine
these things you know if you're drinking
water you're out in the sunshine and
you're exercising out in nature and
you're getting fresh air you didn't have
to think well I just got four of the
eight natural laws and I thought I was
just walking out in nature you know it's
quite interesting
and people don't think about it that
fresh air which has these negatively
charged ions can actually be beneficial
to our levels of happiness they've
actually done a specific study on this
in a office situation people didn't know
and they began to pump in you there's
actually these negative ion generators
like machines that can literally because
it's typical indoor air because of
there's probably several reasons whether
it's the electronics or maybe heating
system various things potentially can
create negative are positively charged
ions or maybe even just our breathing so
without a good open air source from the
outdoors or a negative ion generator
which most of us don't have it you're
not getting this good fresh air that you
need and so doing this day in day out
hour after hour after hour can actually
be kind of depressing and so when they
begin to pump this into a office
situation it ended up having beneficial
impact to the cognition of the people
that were inside the office area and so
for most of us who probably aren't gonna
buy a negative ion generator we can open
the window you know you can do something
where you can get good fresh air in the
you know in the actual building itself
so it's a very simple one but another
thing is that even with sleeping so when
you're sleeping it's good to have the
window open so you're constantly having
that airflow and not just fresh air but
also cool air it's important that you
have that cool air coming in and it has
to be dark and quiet these are all
things that help you have better sleep
because sleep is so important to our
mental health yes
so wherever we're at it doesn't matter
what the weather is we always crack the
window open it even in Michigan it can
be like 10 degrees outside and we
normally unless we're in somebody's
house and we're like man they're gonna
get angry because the air conditioned
our they the heater is going to turn on
so much but like you know if you got a
wood stove or something you heat your
house that way you don't have to worry
about you crack the window and you're
you're cool so but having good fresh air
it's a simple thing but these these
principles of reversing depression not
that I think this is the key this is
just the first thing we're looking at
but the more you put these things
together you know you can have a form of
synergy as they come together so one of
them you may think that's not a big deal
but hey if if you're depressed why not
do everything you can give your body and
your brain the best fighting chance so
that you can hopefully you know by the
grace of God overcome this particular
issue and this is from a book called
healthful living and it says air is the
free blessing of heaven the word heaven
you know it can mean this you know good
you know sure you can think of heaven
but it can also mean the sky you know
like we have this great blessing
calculated to electrify the whole system
and that's what we see here that it has
this you know great blessing the effects
produced by living in close ventilated
rooms are these the system becomes weak
and unhealthy the circulation is
depressed the blood moves sluggishly
through the system because it is not
purified and vitalized by the pure
invigorating air of heaven or the fresh
air and the mind becomes depressed and
gloomy while the whole system is
innervated and fevers and other acute
disease are liable to be generated so
getting that fresh air is just so so
very beneficial something that simple
and it's the good thing is it's unless
you're buying a negative ion generator
it's free what about having plants in
the house you know that probably is I've
never said I haven't looked at a study
specifically on it but it would make
sense because we know that plants are
you know they're gonna give off oxygen
we're giving them our carbon dioxide so
I'm guessing you probably do get some of
the negative ions generated by it I've
just never looked at a particular study
on but it makes sense you know you and I
were talking about Australia and having
visited there and yeah and I think
that's one of the contributing factors
because anytime I go to the beach I just
love being at the beach you know yeah it
always feels relaxed doesn't it it
always feels refreshed make you feel
more peaceful after going to the ocean
yeah and so you think about most of
Australians are probably gonna be living
pretty close to the coast that's right
and they're getting that influx of fresh
air that nice cool breeze yeah that
you're talking about all the time in
California of course being another one
of those places
and you know not all Californians are
you know free of depression or anything
I think that helps yes yeah given the
high amount of stress that they have
yeah and all that so I just love going
to the beach it's very relaxed it really
is but but being in the mountains too
yeah you know secondarily some of us
have heard of sad seasonal affective
disorder and roughly like six percent of
Americans struggle with this that when
the fall months begin to move in you
have less and less sunshine in
depression yeah they become more
depressed and so the one of the things
that we can do that see if you if you
live down in the southern portions of
the country like you know hit we're in
Tennessee right now I we live right now
we're in the process of moving to
Michigan from South Dakota in in those
northern regions you cannot get enough
sunshine to actually produce vitamin D
in the winter so you can get out in it
and the Sun can hit you but there's not
it's not high enough into the sky to hit
enough that it can actually produce
vitamin D so but we're not talking
specifically about vitamin D here but
you just have a lower level of light
that time of year and so many people
become depressed in the fall to winter
season seasonal affective disorder and
it's very common but the the front line
research shows at the front line
the best method of overcoming or the
most popular and it works fantastically
is light therapy and since some regions
of the world like we've lived in Iceland
we're just in Norway a few weeks ago and
in these regions especially when you get
up further like in Norway you have like
weeks and weeks and weeks where the Sun
literally doesn't come over the horizon
it's dark right on stop you're in the
winter they'll get a little bit of like
blueish to the sky but they're but it
doesn't actually produce sunlight and so
you can imagine how prone people are to
depression and those kind of situations
and so you can't get the Sun you can't
just like ah let's just go on the Sun so
what do you do so you get these light
boxes
they're affordable now they used to be
more expensive but now they're
affordable you can get them online
I'm guessing 30 40 50 60 maybe 100 but
you can get it cheaper you can get it
cheaper and you don't look at it
directly just like you don't look at the
Sun directly you put it off to the side
and you let it hit the side if your your
eyes you know where it's hitting your
eyes but not directly and you can just
sit in front of it for like a half-hour
in the morning to get yourself on a
circadian rhythm and you should buy a
box that says at least 10,000 Lux that's
lus so 10,000 Lux is is something
that'll be beneficial and you get to
have enduring devotions or you can sit
and read your Bible in the morning or
something though does it kick your body
into vitamin D production it doesn't is
it I believe they have it you're not
supposed to be getting vitamin D
actually from those particular lights
it's actually just supposed to be
lighting the eyes enough okay that it
somehow creates you know that happy
feeling you have it in summer you know
so it's just giving that experience and
not actually creating vitamin D so this
doesn't seem to be so much a vitamin D
factor as it is just the actual light
honey eyes because you need the cycle of
light and dark and so places like
Iceland where they just have short
amount of light and like I said you
don't see the Sun you just see light and
then it's gone how do you know when to
sleep you don't know what I'm sleep and
then the same thing happens in the
summer it's just light like 24 hours a
day it is hard to sleep at night
yeah it it's extreme both ways because
then in the summer you're up all the
time yeah so you can understand how
things could get off for it for you you
know for your timing so it's important
that you also get to bed at a good time
so that your melatonin will hit a peak
before midnight because you know how it
is when you go to sleep after midnight
when you wake up you never you could
have like 10 hours of sleep and you'll
never feel no because there's a time
that you're supposed to go to bed at
least like three hours before midnight
or something like that and then if you
want peace if you want that that peak of
the melatonin to go up if you get to bed
after that the
peak won't hit as much and so you don't
get that and most don't get it before
midnight but you but it's best even
further especially for people who are
depressed and that's actually our last
point that we're heading out now is that
getting to bed closer to 9 o'clock
especially if people are depressed
especially if they struggle with
depression that that early to bed can
make you know it can make a significant
difference yeah you think about all the
times you may not have had enough sleep
how you are the next day yeah
or anybody it's just like you feel like
a bear yeah it's not no I feel yeah sure
so imagine all the Americans we know I
think I think it's provably you know
accurate that most Americans don't get
enough of sleep I think I've seen that
multiple news reports and so we're just
a bunch of crabby people yeah well and
it affects rubbing off on each other
yeah it affects several areas of our
life and you know this light obviously
natural light is the best but once again
there are situations where you can't get
it so that's where these light boxes
come in if somebody's used to working
indoors all the time and they can't get
it even if it is outside they can still
consider the light boxes if that's if
that's the option for them you know
there's a it's interesting because the
Bible actually said thousands of years
ago in the book of Ecclesiastes this is
this is awesome
it says truly the light is sweet and a
pleasant thing it is for the eyes to
behold the Sun I mean they recognized
thousands of years ago that this that
there's something pleasant about the Sun
hitting your eyes no not like they were
all staring up at the Sun or something
like that meaning just you know it just
feels good you're out there in the Sun
and you just you know obviously you feel
nice on the skin too but something about
hitting the eyes it's a pleasant thing
it's something it's just a happy brings
happiness to our life and so yeah I was
just thinking it's a such a fitting
metaphor for Christ you know says I am
the light of the world you think about
this thing that we all need everywhere
you know shining down upon us to give us
different physiological and emotional
effects and God is saying I'm the same
way like you need me like you need light
yeah their life to be you know to help
in all aspects it's like you can live
without it to a degree but it's like you
look much
with it yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah you
know just kind of review so we've looked
at negative ions we've looked at light
therapy and the next one that we look at
here is basically we about a plant-based
diet and this is interesting I'm gonna
show a video clip but before I do I want
to share with you some very interesting
things about Daniel chapter one we
talked about this a little bit on the
other video but it's quite interesting
when you look at the history of Daniel
Daniel was a young keeper boy taken from
Babylon which was just outside of
modern-day Baghdad Iraq and he so he's
taken out of the capitol of the of the
you know empire of Babylon he was taken
captive he was taken from Jerusalem to
Babylon I should correct myself he was
taken from Jerusalem where he's from
uses a young Hebrew boy taken to Babylon
while he was there he was put into a
three year educational system which
really would be kind of nice because he
gets to be one of like the you know
scholars of Babylon one of the wise men
of Babylon and he was given the best
food that the king could give to them
and obviously most cultures believe the
very best food that makes you the
healthiest is me right meat-based diet
is what you want to eat to be healthy
and and so but Daniel he knew that some
of that meat might be the meat that he
wasn't supposed to eat according to the
Bible so Daniel his friends in Chapter
one decide to go on a plant-based diet
and you know it says but Daniel purposed
in his heart that he would not defile
himself with the portion of the Kings
meat nor with the wine which he drank
therefore he requested at the Prince of
the eunuchs that he might not defile
himself so he said no I want to avoid
this stuff you know I'm not gonna defile
myself with this food and then it says
in verse 12 test your servants the new
translations they prove your servants I
beg of you for 10 days and let them give
us Paul steeped in water to drink now
Paul says it's things that are grown
from seeds so Daniel and his friends go
on a they go on a you know a ten day
total plant-based diet the people around
them say no no you're gonna get
unhealthy if you just see plans you're
gonna be totally unhealthy and it ends
up that Daniel and his friends actually
get healthier they look healthier and
they end up having better cognate
their mental state becomes actually
better and we see that in Chapter you
know one verse 18 it says now at the end
of the days the King said had said he
should bring in these students before
him then the Prince of the eunuchs
brought them and he brought the students
in before the king who was
Nebuchadnezzar the king of Babylon and
the King communed with them and among
them all was found none like Daniel
Hananiah Mishael and Azariah those were
his friends who chose to eat a
plant-based diet
therefore they stood before the king in
all matters of wisdom and understanding
that the King inquired of them he found
them ten times better than all the
magicians and astrologers that were in
all his realm so what Daniel and his
friends ate what went into their gut
affected their brain once again this gut
brain connection and this I find
amazingly fascinating this right here is
an article that's on the National
Institutes of Health website the United
States National Library of Medicine and
the title of this article is evolution
of clinical research a history of before
and beyond by James Lynch so the article
is there looking at the history of
scientific studies and and this is what
the article says it says 562 BC that
that's over 2,500 years ago the world's
first clinical trial is recorded in the
Book of Daniel in the Bible and then it
refers to as goes on to talk about the
experiment right and so we know what the
experiment was the experiment was Daniel
and his friends will go on a plant-based
diet you have a control group that's all
the other wise men of Babylon they stay
on a standard Babylonian diet and the
one group ends up being healthier their
mind functions better and Daniel lives
we know a very long time because he
lived till the time of meat of Persia
and when you know the history we realize
Daniel lived to be quite an old man
which is what happens today
statistically plant-based eaters are the
longest living people in the world today
and I want to show you so you say okay
that's a twenty five hundred year old
study I mean does it still work today
right I mean like oh that's kind of cute
you know but I'm going to show you a
video clip from our documentary called
ancient health where we where we go
around and record health professionals
looking at the science and the research
and this is from our documentary ancient
health it it literally changed my life
actually the process of producing this
film that helped me to overcome the
depression and literally change my life
and this is just a kind of a clip from
this so I should clip but the main thing
that folks should be concerned about is
how long you live and how likely are to
get disease and there been three major
studies published on this subject big
meta analyses and these meta analyses
and only three big ones have been
published they show consistently that
low-carb diets in other words low plant
food diets high animal food diets
consistently they show that they're
associated with more heart disease and
more death more mortality if you look
around the world and you look at these
people in the Blue Zones the the average
percentage of calories from carbs range
from ranges from about 50 percent to
about 80 percent it carbs are not the
enemy refined carbs are the enemy there
have been a number of recent studies dr.
B's holed out of Phoenix Arizona first
she did an observational study showing
that plant-based diet actually
significantly improves your depression
and anxiety stress score it's called a
da SS score so the mood actually is
improved when you get the right amount
of carbohydrates but also the right type
of carbohydrates and less protein then
she followed up with an interventional
study and that's where she took people
who are not on a plant-based diet and
put them on a plant-based diet for two
weeks she also put him on a plant-based
diet plus fish for two weeks to see
which one would be superior and it
turned out the fish diet wasn't any more
superior than the carnivore diet but the
plant-based diet significant dramatic
changes statistically significant
changes in just two weeks in their
mental ability we see when people go on
this diet and drink plenty of water get
plenty of rest followed these natural
remedies that they it's just like
something snaps in their brain and it
doesn't take like weeks or months
plant-based diet is key in our program
for depression
xiety recovery the results are
outstanding because it's a comprehensive
approach not just diet we also utilize
exercise and were utilizing correct
thoughts and a lot of different
modalities but the diet is a key element
I want on a plant-based diet about five
weeks ago it's amazing
because I even if they had had not told
me he had the diet change the first
thing I noticed was he was bringing his
schoolwork in and my teacher is actually
been bragging on how much better I've
been behaving since I've been on the
diet in class he wasn't getting us
distracted that he was paying attention
he was able to listen more closely he
was being alert his dissonant was better
he was more diligent everything I can
pay attention more my mind is more clear
since I've been on the diet it's just a
huge improvement
and I was so noticing less than one away
I mean but the main things I noticed was
behavioral a study in a middle school
has showed clearly that's switching the
menu from animal source to plant source
diet almost eliminated absenteeism
increased and an enhanced attention and
homework performance and performance at
school it it almost eliminated acts of
violence as well as teen pregnancies and
so they just feel better everywhere the
blood flows everywhere that perfect
circulation goes they feel better not
just in body but in mine clears up their
thoughts even in every single day since
I've been on a plant-based diet the
clarity continues to increase and my
face continues to look younger and my
body feels like I feel like I look more
vibrant like I've looked at pictures of
myself before and after and I look five
years older even just ten months ago
than I do now what we eat does get
turned into neurotransmitters it
actually helps us or hurts us depending
on what we're eating in regards to our
brain chemistry and it plays a vital
role
and health of the brain they'll say
within three or four days they there
they seem to have clarity they get there
they're alert they can they listen a
class better they absorb more and they
do better on their tests the fog has
been lifted out of my head I think
clearer I've got better ideas I believe
I can I can put two and two together
faster and just in general I'm happier
in fact diet alone studies show that
diet alone will reduce your depression
and anxiety scores by half just by
dramatically changing your diet to a
plant-based and so that's significant
now we go for more than just half and so
that's why we have a whole program that
includes more than this but just the
diet alone will make a big difference
you don't have to choose between high
quality living and longevity it's the
same program the same Newstart approach
to living helps you live longer and it
helps you live better so a couple
questions one where did we get that
documentary oh yeah so we our website is
Anchor Point films calm and so it's a
documentary called ancient health and
this in much of what we're talking about
in this message is not only on this
documentary but separately we have a
whole video series on the gut brain
connection which also has a section of
it on reversing depression part of it is
on the gut brain connection and that's
affect and then some of the some of it
also talks about some of the stuff that
we'll be talking about here but there's
a much more information on there
okay so Anchor Point films calm and
we'll put the link in the description
below next question is it seems like
there's increasing amount of scientific
evidence to support that a plant-based
diet is the way to go but there's also
an overwhelming consensus in the
Christian community that you know can
eat whatever you want it doesn't matter
but we don't see Daniel doing that you
know in fact it seems like Daniels very
cognizant of the fact that I can make a
choice
and he realizes that between what God
has asked him to do and what he can do
there's gonna be a vast difference yeah
I think I think there's you know even
within the Bible one of the great things
I love about God and the Bible is is the
recognition of choice I mean you have
back in the Book of Joshua well the
question goes forth choose you this day
whom you will serve
meaning God doesn't force anybody nobody
has to follow God right and even God's
law in Deuteronomy 624 where it says
that God gave us all his Commandments or
all of his statutes for our good
always so the commandments are for our
good but then the next part of the verse
says that he might preserve us alive as
it is this day meaning in God's
principles that he gives in the Bible
there's a longevity factor meaning that
we are more likely to live a long life
if we choose to follow God's principles
now you don't have to sure meaning like
if you don't want to yeah you know it's
not like the Bible says you have to eat
a plant-based diet I don't believe that
it forces I mean you know we see people
in the Bible you and even Jesus say you
know fish at least we know that but but
the reality is animals also weren't as
toxic back then as they are now
the reality is even like there's just
looking at something yesterday and farm
farm raised fish are actually more toxic
than ocean fish yeah an ocean fish many
of them still have high levels of PCBs
or or mercury and these kind of things
and so you didn't have that level of
toxic nature in the oceans and on the
world back then so part of it today is
people may say yeah but you get toxins
from plants - you do but not nearly to
the same level as you do from the
animals that are eating those things and
it accumulates in the body of the animal
and then so bioaccumulates or bio
magnifies it in the animal then you eat
it then you have higher levels of that
so and the plant kingdom has the ability
to have a way to counteract the poisons
right so there's antioxidants and all
types of things in in
that can help us can help us shed those
things for example they they say that
brown rice in particular coming from
Arkansas in that area southern states
southern states increase it has an
increase in arsenic because they used to
put arsenic on the cotton fields as a
pesticide and it worked but the problem
is it put arsenic in the soil so then
when you then when you raise rice on
those fields what are you guys really
the rice actually sucks it up it's thin
as you eat it you're getting arsenic in
your food but the fascinating thing is
that another plant helps counteract that
and pull it onto your body which is
sweet potatoes
if you eat sweet potatoes with that rice
the let amine their high levels the only
other thing that's higher I think is
chickens right chicken has a high level
of arsenic and so anyway eating eating
Whole Foods in particular sweet potatoes
with your brown rice is about you can
counteract the toxins no we're not
saying you toxins that's not the goal
but but it's just not the same as sorry
animal it's a lower risk
because animal food isn't giving you
antioxidants it's not giving you these
things to help fight the fiber and for
yeah so so it seems like going back to
Daniel there's a couple of interesting
things going on here one here he
recognizes I'm about to be in an
environment of education so if I'm gonna
do better in this educational
environment I need to be eating this
particular diet but I also sit here and
wonder now that you're talking about
this easy also maybe thinking ahead and
realizing look I'm in a I'm in a place
in time where temptation could be high
and so you go back to the last program
where we talked about you know there are
things that you can do to help build up
your willpower you know to help prevent
you from falling into temptation no
doubt there were probably attractive
women and of course there's alcohol I
know there's all these things that he
could get addicted to yeah so to speak
but I wonder if he was kind of thinking
ahead and saying you know
if I if I indulge here it's gonna make
it I could I could fall yeah later
yeah yeah and as I read the Book of
Daniel
I don't think there's anything that the
Bible says a single thing negative about
him ya know you can't find anything if
you see in Daniel 1 he said you know
Daniel only purpose in his heart so even
before he was faced with that he already
had the purpose yeah right he made that
decision I I'm going to and you know
that that's a key point that especially
for anybody but especially someone you
know a lot of you know we talked about
overcoming addictions and so forth and
the other you know our other meeting but
the reality is there is there is
something about making a decision I'm
not gonna do this anymore well I'm gonna
avoid this and I'm not gonna you know
certain things are better just to avoid
altogether because sometimes being
moderate in them makes you a drug addict
you know it's like it'd be better just
to avoid the drug all together rather
than be a drug addict and so making that
determine that determination I am going
to avoid this and we see we see what
it's done in schools they're talking
about how when this is implemented they
said they said a school implemented this
and what happened it almost eliminated
absenteeism it enhanced their
performance in school their performance
in homework and it almost eliminated
teen pregnancies and violent I mean that
is so diet can literally transform
people's lives and Daniel wasn't in this
environment where it was just like
everything's all of a sudden happy now I
mean he was taken from his home taken
from his parents the only thing that he
had their familiarity was a few people
that he knew some of his friends but it
wasn't just like hey you know I'm going
off to school now at Babylon you yeah
you know I'm gonna study engineering or
whatever it was like no you're taken
from everything that you've known your
whole environment and now you're in a
new environment so stress is high yeah
you know certainly and you would think
the tendency for depression would
increase for sure based on his
circumstance yes yeah and you think
about it he is in literal Babylon
and his story as we look at it teaches
us how to live in spiritual Babylon in
the prophecies and Daniel talked about
at the end of time at the end of time
what you know about spiritual Babylon
that the world would be like battle yeah
and and so as we look at his life we can
have an example for us how to live in
Babylon and yet still be grateful to God
so it's really a beautiful like you said
there's nothing in there that tells us
that he you know was anything wrong that
he hadn't done anything wrong right no
he wasn't perfect we're not saying that
but you don't see him in rebellion or
anything like that which like you said
he had plenty of reason to be he lost
his family never to them again
he had it never never so him being
spiteful and angry or lashing out at
people or using its position of power to
cut other people down and say you know
we're to go against him nothing like
that you don't see anything I mean is
just like complete integrity the whole
way through
totally and one of the things we saw in
the video is that he mentioned this
study with a doctor by the name of
beasts Holt who showed that when people
go on a plant-based diet they compared
three things a meat-based diet mm-hmm a
fish and vegetable source diet and just
plant Bors the source diet the only
group that it has enhancing you know
their mental state their cognition their
happiness was the ones who only were on
plants and one of the potential
causative factors of the negativity of
the animal foods are something is
something called a rakha donek acid
which is something that is in the animal
foods that is we eat it increases
inflammation in the body more
inflammation statistically leads to
higher levels of not only depression but
also lifestyle diseases heart disease
diabetes or so forth but Michelle had
you changed your lifestyle some years
ago had you changed from like a medium
animal-based diet to a plant-based diet
yes what happened I started to become on
a plant-based diet when I came to the
United States okay somewhere from meat
diet you know I mean what country what
country from Indonesia Indonesia okay
yeah so
you know Indonesia we eat a lot of fried
foods there's a lot of oils me and
everything but when I change to
plant-based diet I really feel the
difference you know I used to be my
endurance was bad and right now I like
to exercise and my endurance is better
and also I used to be underweight so it
was unhealthy and right now I actually
become in a healthy weight and you know
some people think if you go to a
plant-based diet you become skinny and
unhealthy but well you know I become
better that's how you know you know for
me when I so I went on like a whole food
plant-based like lifestyle and before in
high school I could run a mile in 9
minutes and something not a very good
mile but then going on a whole food
plant-based diet in my mid-30s I gave it
a try and with without with very little
practice running I ran a mile in like 5
minutes and 50 some seconds you know
which which is no professional mile but
it's much better than it used to be like
you know and so it just is literally
like the endurance what you what you
stated it increases your ability to to
endure you feel it's just easier to
breathe and just your energy level goes
up and not to mention the happiness
factor which to me is even better than
the endurance although I love the
endurance that's that's a real blessing
so so with that the diet like you said
gives you more energy to exercise and
exercise is one of the things that's our
next point to overcome depression right
so you realize some people struggle to
exercise but could it be that they're
eating the things that caused them to be
sluggish I don't feel like exercising is
like related yeah very related and like
we said earlier it's a synergistic
effect you can't just do one you need
them all together to have the full
benefit and so depression they actually
show that is it possible to run away
from your depression right can you run
away from it and they also show that it
directly affects exercise directly
affects your gut biome yeah in which I
don't even know how that
works I mean it's almost miraculous
because we know that eating certain
foods eating you know since there's a
bunch of good bacteria on the fruits and
vegetables as you eat it you you know
they go into your system and so you have
additional beneficial bacteria but
exercise alone chose to increase
beneficial bacteria in the gut and it
may be because it doesn't kill off
certain bacteria and maybe lack of
exercise actually kills off bacteria and
maybe the exercise I don't know that's
just just surmising that that may be the
case but the reality is you have more
beneficial bacteria in your gut when you
exercise so exercise is a very important
factor in our health so there's a study
called smile not Stanford medical
intervention and long-term exercise and
what they did is they had a 16 week
trial and they had 156 patients put into
three groups and they had a zoloft group
okay which is wind which is a drug on
medication it's an antidepressant right
in an exercise group and an exercise and
zoloft group so which group do you think
would just off the top of your head
which group do you think would do the
best I'm gonna go with exercise okay
just exercise you know that down you
know I think just logically you would
think maybe it's exercise and so life
gets like one-two punch well we're gonna
find out that you're actually right
let's find out
so the exercise group you're right did
the best so they had them exercise for
30 minutes to 70 to 85 percent of their
target heart rate you can look that up
online to see what your target for your
age what is your target rate so it was
three three times a week that they that
they exercise all had a drop in
depression all three groups sounds good
nearly half of each group were no longer
depressed mmediately after it an
additional 13 percent had less symptoms
but were not totally depression free so
still good but six months later the
exercise group was doing the best
hmm fifty-five percent of the mix group
that was the exercise and Zoloft group
was depressed six months later
so 55% of them were more depressed later
and 52% of the medication group were
depressed so by the way the worst group
was the group that took the medication
and they did the worst Wow
but only 30% of the exercise group was
depressed six months later they did
significantly better but again mind you
if you do all these other things maybe
it would have helped them stay on their
exercise program right let's say you
start
you've never exercised before and you
start to know like man I feel so good
but then you go out to eat you need all
manner of things are you gonna feel
great to exercise the next day no you're
gonna be sluggish and the plant-based
diet also helps hasten your recovery so
your recovery time is shorter so that
you know you don't have as you know
because if you're eating junky food till
you get really sore and you're like man
that's why I never exercise cuz you feel
so terrible you know but the good thing
is when you do it regularly your body
begins to adapt to it you're not sore
all the time so you don't have that
terrible and and sometimes you even have
a good sore you know like there's a good
sword versus like that terrible like oh
my whole body feels bad you know like
nobody really likes that feeling but
like just a little bit of soreness
sometimes actually feels good you know
so for example we were talking about the
Tennessee Titans 15 of NFL team that 15
players yeah so 15 of them are vegan
during season and when you hear them
talk about it they'll say things like my
recovery time is so much better look I I
recover so much better than when they're
on a meat-based diet then their recovery
time is longer so I bet you these guys
could play a lot more than 16 games and
a season right they heal fast yes yes
yeah for them I mean they've only got a
limited time where they're in their
prime and they and they're doing all
these things to really decrease their
prime yeah they aren't so if they can
extend that I mean it's just money in
the bank for them totally don't there so
most people will exercise because they
think they're gonna lose weight but
that's actually not the best thing not
the best way to lose weight actually
look at how many miles do you have
to walk off a pound how many miles did
you do you have to walk to give a guess
[Music]
I'm gonna say so if you want if you want
to lose a pound
just by exercise alone you need to do 35
miles of exercise so you need it's more
than a marathon so you like a marathon
isn't good enough you have to run or
walk or run 35 miles and so people don't
think about the physics of it but
walking and running cause the same
amount of calories it's just faster
running because meaning like it's about
mass how big are you and how fast how
far are you moving that mass so like a
mile of run versus a mile of walk sheds
about the same amount of calories
rushing she do it faster when you run
because you're running and yeah this
time exactly sorry but still 35 miles so
that's like I mean if someone's going
seven days a week when she stressed one
day anyway but nevertheless if you did
seven days a week you're talking like
five miles every single day to lose a
pound in a week that you know so that's
not the best like that it seems like
well why would I lose and how many
people like are if they're significantly
overweight are gonna put in five miles
every day I mean it's not likely so
there's a better way which is really
changing to closer to a whole food
plant-based diet your weight begins to
shed unless you're adding a lot of
refined things to the night like sugar
or oil oil can actually keep you from
losing the weight if you're eating
significant because it's very high in
calories for father yourself so in our
ancient health documentary one of the
doctors talks about his wife she's a
dietitian and she had this thing that
she would tell her clients on losing
weight and she'd say it's not what thou
JA ggest it's what thou hast it's Kat
it's the calories that you're putting in
you can't the amount of calories people
put in there's no way you can jog that I
mean you can lose a little but you're
not gonna really make a significant
impact you just can't use all that
energy up and so then your body
stores it so we're not saying don't
exercise oh yeah and mostly though for
the for the cognition for the benefit to
that yes it's good for you know just in
general exercise is phenomenal but it's
not the best thing for losing weight
specifically yeah so we're really better
off running or walking for our mental
health yes then for way not not to say
that it's not good for our physical he's
gonna if we're trying to lose weight
yeah definitely not it's not the main
source a weight loss but it does have a
side effect that helps you lose weight
and this is willpower it actually
enhances your willpower and so then
you're gonna control your your appetite
better and you're disabled you're more
likely to so in that aspect it can be
but it's not about burning calories yeah
so let me ask you a question how long
have you been eating a plant-based diet
so I I went from a meat-based thought to
maybe a vegetarian ish it was well
vegetarian around 19 years ago I'm okay
you how long 20 some she's been she's
been in the twenty some year and yeah so
here's the next question have you ever
had trouble maintaining your weight
since then so here's the thing when I
first became vegan I actually gained
probably I'm guessing five to ten pounds
and that was I was much bigger than this
at the time I was probably about thirty
pounds heavier but I ended up just side
know I had gallbladder issues and so I
had to really go on a low-fat diet and
you can reverse gallbladder issues on a
rugged low-fat plant-based diet you can
actually get rid of stones by going in a
whole whole food plant-based size so
that's I went on that and that's why I
ended up losing weight but but your
general vegan doesn't have to be like
you can be like I said this guy broke
the world record of carrying you know
1,100 pounds 430 feet and he's total
vegan so you can you can depending on
how much protein how much fat you have
you can be bigger I for me I ate a whole
food plant-based diet which got rid of
my gallbladder issues and also helped me
in so many ways from joint pain to
migraines you know helped with the
depression so I helped me in so many
levels I happen to be thinner than I
used to be but I feel so good that I
love it like it's just such a good
experience that like I don't
go love it did you ever count your
calories no but I eat people are blown
away at the quantity of food that I eat
and my wife they look at us little
skinny people and they're like oh but
then they sit down with us and they're
like do humans eat that much at a meal
you know it's like might you know people
who are large people sit down with us
and we eat more than almost anybody but
the thing is when it's whole food and
nothing refining I mean nothing yeah
no oil no no sugar no whatever you can
eat significant amounts because there's
not many calories people think old
potatoes make you fat nobody gets fat
our potatoes it's what do you put on the
potato it's like okay you put it you
know you put in oil you know Duke fry it
and you blame them you blame you blame
the potato instead of blaming the you
know fried potato right you know and so
you know we blamed the wrong thing many
times when it's actually not that and so
a long story short a whole food diet
just naturally you get thinner it just
it just happened so but but each of us
has to work with what we have so he had
gallbladder issues well it was because
he was eating a high fat even a vegan I
was eating a high fat vegan diet so I
was eating a lot of like vegan butters
and those kind of things and and then
I'm getting my grandfather died of a
gallbladder surgery grandma had
gallbladder surgery my aunt had it and
I'm struggling even on a plant-based
diet with it cuz I'm eating a high-fat
plant-based diet but when I talked with
a doctor on her documentary and she said
if you want to reverse that you've got
to change your diet you got to cut out
and so for me I'm not telling everybody
else what they have to do but if they
struggle like I do with the gallbladder
issues it's something to consider yeah
most people just get it cut out but me I
I'm just a guy who like I'd like to keep
as much of my body if possible you know
if I had to have it cut out it's like
okay you know go under the knife but
it's I don't have to you know and I can
just change a lifestyle habit you know
and here's the thing you think what
happened in the end I love it like I
enjoy food just as much now as I've ever
actually maybe more than ever and so
even though it's different it's only
different for a time and different
becomes normal so so if you completely
cut out the oils I do on our own on our
own we do it's it's it's the same diet
that's been proved the only diet in the
history of Earth that's yet been proven
scientifically to reverse our disease to
reverse the plaque in the diet is not
just a vegan diet
but it is a it is a low-fat vegan diet
where next to no oil or no oil has been
the only diet that's been improving to
be able to reverse heart disease so like
it the s Holstein diet or the Ornish
diet or these the mcdougal diet these
kind of things are all basically whole
food plant-based and so we do and you
know for people who struggle with some
things like us some people they'll live
long eating oil you know they won't be
as bad but for people like us we because
of and help my wife out she ended up
having it helped her with Candida you
know it helped her with that also and we
actually need a very high carb diet and
a high fruit diet we're not we're not
like only fruit veggies and nuts and
grains and so forth but eating a very
high carb diet without oil is what
actually got rid of her Candida which
they generally say don't eat fruit and
don't do this but I found very few
people who get better on a candida diet
candida diet seem to keep people stuck
generally with Candida they say Oh eat a
bunch more fat avoid the carbs avoid the
fruit and they just they're stuck with
Candida
whereas we did the opposite we got rid
of the and I could go on and on about
the science of why but we don't have
time for that long story short it worked
for us we shared this in Hawaii as we
were we were a group of medical
professionals that invited us to come
and speak on health and they invite us
come speak and we were speaking lady
came up she tried the same thing she had
Candida for years tried the candida diet
high fat diet low carb didn't work went
on this and it worked for her too so she
wrote us several months later hey it
were it worked
yeah but yeah so we'll move forward well
go on with the depression so so back to
our so here we have exercise you know is
is the last thing we talked about the
benefits of exercise it's fantastic for
reversing depression it's actually
probably one of the best things to be
honest with you next to diet I think
those two things diet exercise and sleep
are some of the very best things you can
do to reverse depression but the next
one is avoiding excess sugar
it has been discovered that people who
ate more sugar were more depressed but
the question remained was it the
depression that caused people to eat
more sugar or was it the additional
sugar that was a causative factor in the
depression and people always have that
question right am I depressed and I want
to eat more sugary foods or are the
sugary foods that I'm eating causing my
depression a study from the University
College London looking at more than
eight thousand adults followed them from
the 1980s discovered that men who at the
moment
the most sugar had a 23 percent higher
likelihood of becoming depressed within
the next five years
Wow so if you eat if you eat refined
foods you're going to have that effect
in the brain we talked about it in the
and the other one you know it loves
carbohydrates but what kind of
carbohydrates is that brain love you
know complete you know Whole Foods
that's the kind of how carbon heart is
not refined foods it does not do well
with refined foods and also it says in
mine character and personality book 2
says sugar is not good for the stomach
it causes fermentation and this clouds
the brain and brings peevishness into
the disposition so sugar especially for
brain workers if you're sitting a lot
and you're doing a lot of thinking it's
it's real important that you're giving
your body the best food possible to to
have brain function also so we talked
about negative ions light therapy
plant-based diet 7.2 servings of fruit
and 8.2 veggies you know this is all to
combat overcome can make you
statistically higher every serving of
fruits or vegetables and well I think
yeah I saw that makes you happier and
then of course we talked about exercise
avoiding sugar and also cats in the
house now this this is an interesting
Wow
this is quite bad almost like I've never
heard anybody talk about this but
research has shown that having cats in
the house increases risk of
schizophrenia and depression both of
these things are because specifically
there is a common parasite within the
stool of cats called Toxoplasma gondii I
yeah and I could tell you some
fascinating research they've done
studies of a significant portion of the
world has this parasite like a
significant portion and people who have
it it increases their likelihood of
having car crashes it makes men more
antisocial and this is a strange one it
makes women more hyper sexual more open
to men sexually strangely enough this
this Toxoplasma gondii a parasite that's
in the you know stool it's the same
thing the reason why they tell women not
to have not to change the litter box
don't change the litter box when you're
pregnant because it can cause blindness
and other issues to your child okay and
so basically long story short it can
increase the likelihood so studies have
shown this there was one study that was
done by cat lovers and I think for the
purpose of showing that it wasn't true
that one study showed that it wasn't
true but the other studies seemingly
show that there is a negative side
effect to it and so something to think
about go ahead go ahead
so if you pick it up you know let's say
you have cats in the house you pick it
up and you know you have these higher
rates of depression how do you get rid
of it because I mean there's the RDA on
it if you already have the issue you
mean maybe you don't have it and you've
had a cat you know one of the things I
would consider that's a good question I
don't know if any studies have shown
this so I can tell you one thing that is
is not it's proven in a separate state
to work for parasites I can't guarantee
it will work for Toxoplasma gondii eyes
so they did a study in countries of the
world that have a lot of parasites
around the equator I mean a lot of those
kind of places where it's warmer
tropical historically what they would do
just kind of folk medicine was they
would take when they when people had
parasites they found they had got
trouble they would eat the seeds of
papaya and so many people don't realize
that that pharmaco pharmaceutical
corporations actually send employees to
like these backwoods areas of the world
the Amazon or different areas to find
out and they'll ask people like hey when
you get a headache what do you do and
right like all we use this Park and we
you know suck on it or or oh we eat this
or and then
they do is they say well maybe there is
something there let's do scientific
studies to find out is this just kind of
like silly folk medicine or is this
legitimate you know they really found
out over thousands of years as a reason
to do so they put to the test in I
believe the country of Nigeria and they
did a legit study on finding out they
took 60 children relatively small study
but 60 children with established within
their stool they saw that they had
parasites within their stool it was the
fact that they knew that so they put
them they had a control group the
control group consumed honey as the you
know medicine and the second group used
honey and the dried seeds of the papaya
and so three grams of dry papaya seeds
is what it was so so what they found is
that the children they divided them into
two groups 30 and 30 30 of the children
just took the honey and they had it
lowered the amount of parasites in them
by 16.7% the second group which ain't
not bad now maybe they would have just
got those out over time anyway I don't
know but the second group or maybe honey
which would make sense honey is a kind
of a it's like an antibacterial kind of
food so maybe it did have an impact but
the second group it lowered them it got
rid of 76 yes as I think 76.6% are right
around there 70 Plus percent it got rid
of their parasites
well that's significant that was one
dosage that was taking it one time
Sophia can I say for sure it will work
for the parasite in cats you know I
don't know it might it might and so my
thought I've taken it personally because
I travel internationally on a regular
basis been to you know you go to a third
world country food you get super sick
did I get a parasite I don't know you
know but it's like you know hey I could
just eat some papaya seeds why I give it
a try right so I did and so I've done
that so it's worth it's worth a try I
cannot give but I would not eat them all
the time I really was I ate them for a
while and it's crazy what happens if you
do it don't don't try it you don't want
to try to me like it's like it's not you
don't want so like maybe try it once
maybe twice but do not
maybe you shouldn't even do it at all I
don't know but one study did show it so
but yeah it's it's something to consider
and you could still enjoy your cat and
let it be
outdoor cat and you know petted or
whatever but having feces of an animal
in the house might might not be the best
thing for mental health or yeah okay but
I know people get furious about that one
so we may see it in the comments section
later people people don't like that one
but hey do whatever you want you know
we're not telling you what to do yeah
all these things are suggestions just
suggestions to choose you do you do what
you want with it okay
also avoid alcohol or any mind-altering
drugs this is real important because you
want your mind to be in the best
condition for making decisions for not
being down you know you get down quite a
bit from from alcohol and drugs but just
to clarify once again you feel better
when you take them yes you feel worse
after they go away so we're not saying
you don't like the reason people do them
is because they feel better but it's
that that long-term effect of it that
you know you don't you you're empty the
next day you're depressed the next day
so yeah it's a point you you smoke you
drink you gamble you get a head of
dopamine yeah you know you feel better
yeah yes but then it goes away and
there's a limit further than where you
were before you started yes yeah then
also sleeping early how would you keep
pounds off and depression away and we
already talked about that so I mean if
you having the best time if you really
struggle with depression
I know nine sounds so early but if you
would get in that habit of going to bed
early and waking up early it's very hard
in the beginning but if you really
really struggle the depression it's
something to really consider trying it's
worth the try you know and you're not
gonna get over your pression in a day or
two within this right so it's a process
of time till your body adapts to your
new schedule you say Ben I'm a night owl
I love staying up and I feel so good but
if you're depressed a friend of ours
who's a medical doctor he he is a saying
he says the body does not lie yeah you
don't feel good your body's telling you
something is wrong there's a great and
great quotation where where it says I
think it's in you know a book called
councils and dying foods where it says
disease is an effort of nature to free
the system from conditions that result
from a violation of the laws of health
in case of sickness the cause should be
ascertained
unhealthful conditions should be changed
then nature is to be assistant assisted
in her effort to expel impurities and to
re-establish right conditions in the
system meaning that that disease is an
effort of your body to tell you
something is wrong you know and once
again we feel like depression is totally
psychological and there there is a
psychological aspect but I actually
believe that in most cases when we begin
to live out healthy principles the mind
begins to just function better we do
have to choose we talked in our last
session about Bible promises and every
time we have negative thoughts or
depressive thoughts or you know desire
for drugs or whatever we want to turn to
the Word of God having a Bible promise
verse
you know the Bible talks about in Scent
Corinthians chapter 10 verse 4 and 5
that the weapons of our warfare are not
carnal they're not fleshly but mighty
through God to the pulling down of
strongholds casting down imaginations
and every high thing that exalteth
itself against the knowledge of God and
bringing into captivity every thought to
the obedience of Christ so the Bible
says God can bring every single thought
we have into captivity that 2nd
Corinthians 10 4 and 5 and he can bring
our thoughts captive now if we have good
thoughts
we saw never forget that thoughts work
out actions repeated actions form habits
and habits form character so if we have
healthy thoughts in the Bible what can
help us when we have unhealthy thoughts
for drugs or for illicit sex or or for
whatever negative aspect we have or
depressive thoughts we can turn them to
the Word of God and as we do God can
help us bring our thoughts captive we
can say father you told me you can bring
every single thought I have captive to
you you can make us victorious and
that's one of the reasons we need to you
know keep our mind on God's Word Jesus
did that to overcome and we can do the
same okay so that's why our last point
as he said is give your life to Jesus
because he's the ultimate restorer not
only a body but also of mine
and Jesus said to he came to give us
life and to give us life more abundantly
more abundantly mean he God wants our
happiness he wants what's best for us
and if we're struggling sometimes like
when I was depressed I felt guilty all
the time
I just every single morning the very
first thought I would have would just be
a just a guilty thought like all you did
this and I would try to make it right or
I you know did all kinds of things to
try to make my life right and just never
felt right and for me it was a
physiological issue once my stomach
began to get better once my gut issues
began to get better the depression just
began to go away and up by the way one
side no if you contact us on our website
Anchor Point films.com some people need
to do a very special diet called the
elimination challenge diet which is
avoiding a bunch of foods that are
actually many of them are actually good
foods but for temporarily avoiding them
because they're so it's basically
getting rid of the common allergens for
one month okay and if you start to
notice like wow I'm feeling better man I
have less achy joints or my depression
is going away and I don't have migraines
now or
various issues like my arthritis is gone
which many people will find on the
elimination challenge diet and we send
it to people free but at anchor point
films.com
go to our website contact us and we can
send you an email free on what the
elimination challenge diet is because
there's many people have allergies to
foods they don't realize sure and when
they avoid them for a month what they do
is then they then so like one of the
foods is a great food apples apples are
one you know fantastic food great for
your health but it's one of the most
common allergens in the fruit family so
so when they avoid this fruit most
people it doesn't affect them probably
99% of people are not affected by apples
but the 1% that is they do better off
without it right and so we're not saying
it's a bad food I think I'm growing
apple trees in my yard and you know I
love apples but but I don't have a
problem with them but so you avoid a
bunch of foods for one month not forever
and then you add them back one at a time
and you see like let's say you add
apples back and now old man like the
next day of achy joints or you're
depressed or whatever which is unlikely
it's apples I'm not it's very unlikely
it's
but but let's see let's see you start
feeling bad then you take it out of your
diet for a while again and then you add
so you wait three days after eating it
so you start feeling better again or
whenever it takes to feel better again
and then you add back the next food and
if nothing negative happens over the
next three days you can keep that food
in your diet the next one in next one
but if some of them show negative side
effects you avoid them you try to avoid
them for six months okay and then you
try adding it back again and sometimes
you know the medical professionals say
that it will actually reverse the
allergy like your body will heal and you
can start eating it again but in some
cases you'll eat it again and you'll
find out no I just I just got to avoid
it so once again it's it's that's more
of an extreme case but it's it's the
kind of thing where like people were
really diligent and willing to try you
know it's a way to do a free test on
your own body or it doesn't cost you any
more you got to get ours anyway so
that's right yeah so something to think
about but yeah just summing up all the
things that we looked at is that these
things as we change our diet as we look
through all these things you know
negative ions getting out in the fresh
air getting adequate light you know in
the summer you can get that attic don't
get burned we're not talking about
burning yourself getting on a
plant-based diet we know that just
removing whether it's removing the you
know meat out of your diet or even the
fish helps lower your depression within
two weeks we saw exercise we have both
avoiding sugar cats in the house you
know put them outside and you can still
you know you know pet them or whatever
and you don't have that nice experience
and help them keep the you know mice and
rats away from your house or whatever
avoid alcohol good sleep and giving your
life to Jesus I just want to say one
thing about the giving your life to
Jesus you know Chad mentioned earlier
that that's one of the things that
helped him in this way you know he said
it was a is a physiological thing for
him right yeah and once he once he cared
that then all the spiritual stuff went
away he wasn't feeling a guilt yeah but
what I say is that had he not had his
aunt his life in the hands of Jesus
every day he'd have been much worse yeah
I was spending time in devotions every
single day trying to make my life right
with
I was actually doing the almost all of
the rest of this I was exercising I was
eating a pretty good diet I was you know
getting light actually using light box
and you know literally almost every
single thing in here although I wouldn't
always go to bed on time which is a
significant factor but then I changed to
like eating significant amounts of
fruits and vegetables like I talked
about and it really like had changed my
life
I was already eating a plant-based diet
but not as good not whole food and
overtime with that government of the
joint pain it got rid of like I said
migraines it got rid of so in it and
when I'm eating it very well it gets rid
of tinnitus the ringing in the ears that
I have I mean so many I had quite a few
health issues and and it got rid of the
depression which to me was the most
significant like within two weeks of I
did something extreme I'll just share it
with you I don't think this is what most
people need to do but it worked for me
since I had a real gut issue and most
people probably shouldn't do this to be
honest with you
but I I read a quotation about basically
the food God gave Adam and and the
benefit it had you know like in in his
sinless state what he ate which was a
total plant-based diet
largely a fruit based diet so for two
weeks I just ate fruit okay and within
two weeks my depression began to go away
and I'm gone so yeah and it was it was
incredible and but most people I don't
think that's their issue most people
weren't eating as well as I was before
that time I was eating to be honest a
very very healthy diet but eating that
way for me but that's because I had
specific gut issues from living in
Iceland and having having stomach
trouble there so most people it's not
like that but a very short-term plant
fruit diet for a day or two or a few
days followed by adding in the veggies
like we showed in our last episode they
it can you can find that very same
benefit but otherwise what would be more
important for most people if they really
really struggle still with with a
plant-based diet would be to consider
doing the elimination challenge diet so
that's that's something to consider also
it seems like if you are having trouble
with anyone
you know you would you would maybe want
to hone in on one of those aspects
that's right I'm not getting sunlight
yes yeah enough fresh air totally like I
know us working in this environment that
we are it's like we're indoors most of
the time especially in the winter it's
like you come to work it's like almost
dark and it's dark
yeah so you're almost it we don't have
any windows in here so it's like we're
we're probably not subjecting ourselves
to the best health because of that yeah
but I know and for myself I'm really
diligent in like other areas to kind of
fight off yeah some of that you know I'm
like really regimented with my water
really resonated with my food yeah yeah
I was exercising really regularly it's
about a month ago and then I fell off
the bandwagon so I need to get back on
that but you know the all these things
it's interesting when you were talking
about how a lot of these things just
shed the analogy came to me like when
people come to Christ they describe the
same kind of experience you know I came
to Jesus and all this guilt and shame
and all these things that I had just
completely went away and it's the same
thing with the health base principles
yeah like we we come to God and that
aspect when we say Christ you know I'm
yours I want to treat my body the way
you've designed it you you know you know
how it works so when I come to you in
that and give it lay all that at your
feet all these things shut away whether
it be pounds anxiety depression
what-have-you just it just falls away
yeah and the great thing about it is too
because sometimes when people hear
Christians talk about healthy eating
they think oh you think you get to go to
heaven based upon what you eat no way
like you can't go to heaven because of
what you eat but the closer you get to
the diet that God made for man in the
beginning cuz he said all my
commandments are for your good right so
all the things I give you they lived in
the Garden of Eden right the word Eden
in the Hebrew language means pleasure it
was the garden of pleasure so the food
that he gave them was best designed for
their pleasure the work he gave them was
best designed for their pleasure and
they've done Studies on all of this we
know that a plant-based diet lowers
depression levels we know that gardening
lowers levels of depression lowers a lot
likelihood of having dementia
it low it lowers your weight it does
like it is one of the most
psychologically and physiologically
beneficial things you can do is
gardening sure you know and it fits this
is what God said so it's not that God
says if you don't garden you don't go to
heaven no no we're not talking about
this we're talking about the closer you
get to implementing the lifestyle that
God gave in the beginning makes you
happier healthier and it may be just
enjoy life better so it makes our time
here while we are here on earth you know
something that we can enjoy more and we
can be a greater benefit to people
around us right about peak performance
peak performance that's a great way of
saying it yeah
and just one more thing going back to
the the whole when he was in the depths
of his depression the it was he said it
was ten years and eight of those was
like seasonal but the last two was was
full you know the whole year yeah to
yourself okay and so so he was really
struggling at that point but he would go
out and spend time in nature and pray
and study and everything and he got to
the point where he thought what if I
have to live with this the rest of my
life and and he contemplated he said he
said well then I guess I'm just gonna
have to do that because what I know just
accept it I'll just accept it he says
where would I go Jesus you have the
words of life
like I knew Jesus was the answer but I
just I didn't feel it yeah sure but
that's a good thing to remember too is
that our salvation is not based upon how
we feel
you don't go to heaven because you feel
like you're going to Evan do you go
because Jesus died for you and your
trust in him even if you don't feel it
right you know you may not feel saved
but in looking back and after gaining
victory over depression I look back and
I don't think I don't believe I was lost
to them right you know I just didn't
feel saved so the good news is and so
you know don't give up one of the things
I could say is you may feel like giving
up you may feel like I just listen Jesus
is the answer even if you don't feel it
Jesus when he was going to the cross he
I mean he prayed to his father when he
was on the cross he said my God my God
why have you forsaken me he felt
completely lost but the good news is
Jesus rose up from the grave and the
reality is for us that even though we
may feel lost if we've given our life to
Jesus accepted him as our personal
Savior turn away from our sins
even if we feel lost we can trust in
Jesus anyway so the good news is I
didn't have to feel that shame and guilt
for the rest of my life I'm glad God
helped me to get through it but don't
give up don't give all the men and he
learned a lot on the way right yeah
that's what he you I said don't don't
give up looking for solutions because
along the way you find something that
will work yeah because I tried you know
cuz people suggested oh you know this
this you know take this supplement or
take this and I tried and tried and
tried and tried and tried and nothing
nothing nothing nothing so some people
be like just give up but I kept trying
and I'm so glad I did because I never
would have found what worked for me and
I don't mean that that one thing that
worked for me will work so well for
other I think all the other things that
I do with a healthy lifestyle actually
did help me from getting too deep that
it would have been overwhelming right so
the other things as we put these things
together as we said there's a synergy so
something to try to really implement as
many obviously in one day you're not
gonna do it all but start with one add
another and just be going to work your
way through yeah that's exactly what
would feel overwhelming to do everything
like this over it would yeah it would so
don't feel like you have to do it all
overnight but work your way you could
even write a list on the fridge and you
know did I get my exercise today did I
drink my water today did I get on fresh
air today and and like they said on the
video you go exercise outside during the
day and you're getting sunlight fresh
air it'll make you want to drink you're
getting exercise I mean you're getting
you know four or five of these things in
one you know one fell swoop so yeah not
that we recommend overdoing the
technology but there are even apps that
will help you build habits you know
that's one actually positive use of
technology help track your water use in
your exercise and and help you form you
know a new habit you know if you need to
be outside every every so long so
technology can be used for a benefit in
that regard well thank you Chad and
fatiah for coming and sharing this you
can see the list I will recommend that
you start implementing at least one of
these in your life if you're noticing
that you are depressed or struggling
with depression and saying man I'm so
down how can I keep going it's very much
like the Christian walk there are times
of discouragement there are times where
you just don't know how you can keep
going but Christ tells us in his word
you know that he who endures to the end
you
we'll be saved and it's not gonna say
that you're not gonna struggle through
that process but there is an end and
Christ will help see you through it so
thank you for joining us if you have any
comments leave them in the leave them
below and we will put the links for you
about Anchor Point films and the
documentaries they've created also in
the description below and we just thank
you guys for coming and sharing that
information with our viewership and our
audience and don't purchase or don't
forget to subscribe hit that Bell so you
can be notified when the next video
comes out this has been LED live and we
hope to see you next time take care
you
[Music]